[Music]
um
are you
[Music]
ready for the
this is a denizen of the russian
republic of dagestan believe it's dugga
snap and if i'm not mistaken for all the
mma fans he's an undefeated mma fighter
and i'm going to go ahead and discuss
some peculiar idiosyncrasies you've seen
him do it some things he's done some
things he said
during some of his fights
so you can appreciate i'm sure you will
appreciate when you can connect it to
something you're familiar with in the
winner by submission due to kimura
[Music]
now let's start off with what he's doing
here this is not just particular to him
you'll see many people who want to keep
it humble and who are thankful and
grateful they point up
pointing up to the one up above up above
the creation up above the heavens in the
universe the one who created this whole
universe the galaxies the seven seas
everything in this world
isn't he not worthy of all praise and
things and that's what he's doing
because people become very arrogant and
this is something we have to be very
very careful of and we can all take a
lesson from this to keep it humble
to keep it humble you cannot go wrong
with keeping it humble arrogance will
get you lost
we'll lose your friends who likes to be
around arrogant people and at the end
failure
failure at the end
[Music]
why is he putting his face on the ground
what's he doing kissing the ground but
let me connect it because the point was
if i can if we can connect it to
something that you are familiar with
someone who you're familiar with
you're probably going to appreciate it a
lot more you might even start doing it
and
if something works
if it's gonna
help improve your life
why not give it a try
and check this out you know jesus we
know g ev i mean did you know muslims
love jesus there's this fighter
here if anyone knows who he is he's
wearing uh he's he's another mixed
martial arts fighter he's got a he's got
a shirt on
talking about how muslims love jesus did
you know that so if you're a khabib
khabib fan you've learned something
already
and you'll see that muslims they have a
deep reverence and love for jesus as a
mighty messenger who was sent
just like abraham knowing all the other
messengers calling people to connect
with the one who gave us these abilities
these gifts in life
like khabib was given some very talented
athlete
and and he's acknowledging that this is
from the creator and now again he's
taking it a step further and just like
jesus and related to someone you know
jesus in the gospel of matthew 26 39 it
says that he went and he went a little
further and he fell on his face
and pray to god
isn't that amazing this is something
that habib doing not only him but
muslims 1.7 billion human beings and
muslim is simply one who surrenders who
submits himself not to a man
not to a woman not to money not to fame
not to anything
or anyone but to the creator up above is
that beautiful do you learn something
already he's doing what all the prophets
of god did so it shouldn't be next time
you see him do that next time you're a
fan of khabib and you see you see him
fighting at the end and if he wins god
willing and he prostrate he puts his
head on the floor you can connect it now
you watch this you say oh he's doing
what jesus did he's giving praise and
thanks keeping it humble
excuse me guys
alhamdulillah now let's move on to the
next thing what he said he said some
some words now sometimes when we hear
something in another language we can't
appreciate it excuse me guys
alhamdulillah i want to say something he
says alhamdulillah
[Applause]
what does that mean why is he saying
something
in another language in arabic now i want
to connect this again back
to the one i'm sure many christians who
love jesus people who aren't even maybe
christian but they heard jesus they have
they have a connection to him do you
know that jesus he called on the creator
if you ever watched the passion of
christ
[Music]
allah
in arabic it's just allah this is the
creator we're talking about
and he is saying alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
everything god gave me
so again he's keeping it humble if
anything we could take away from this
video is is is that quality of keeping
it humble we got too much we're all
susceptible to it ego
the ego can take over and you become
very arrogant who likes to be around
arrogant people keeping it humble again
he's saying alhamdulillah it's just like
saying thank you god
everything god gave me
very simple now you're going to preach
can you appreciate that let's go on to
the next thing
and the last but not the least
allah
what does it mean is it some war cried
jihad they're coming to get us how
ridiculous does that sound but that's
what some people think do you know that
over
60 000 books in a span of a hundred
years have been written against islam
according to
the times magazine article published in
1979 april 16th i believe it was
and that the islamophobia industry is a
250
million dollar annual business
so you know probably the information you
got
the book you read false propaganda
fear-mongering
and the hate-mongers they're making
money bashing throwing dirt on islam so
allahu akbar is not a war cry
it's simply allah god is greater greater
than that money that dollar that job
that woman
everything that you can imagine god
almighty the creator allah is greater
than this and again going back to
keeping it humble always stanking
the one who gave you the abilities to
win that championship
to get up in the morning
to eat the wonderful food to breathe
this air you don't got to go to walmart
to get it it's free
so you say god almighty is great it's
like saying hallelujah hallelujah you've
heard that
but god almighty is the greatest
so that's what khabib is saying i'll
help you to
familiarize yourself with some of the
things that he does what muslims do in
general because khabib is a muslim one
who has consciously submitted to the
creator of the heavens and earth
and some of those stereotypes that one
might have in the back of his head he's
heard this term allahu akbar now if you
were to equate because islam is a
beautiful way of life calling you have
peace
with the creator peace within yourself
so you can have that peace that money
can't buy and you have peace with
humanity if you were to take all the
isis and the boko haram and al-qaeda
which which didn't even exist a decade
ago it's because all of these wars is
that hate
war hate violence terrorism cycle that
we got to stop innocent blood here there
everywhere is human life we got to
condemn one condemn all and when you
have any large group of people you're
going to have radicals you're going to
have extremists but we also have to see
what's the root of all this and islam is
not the root my friends
no islam brings that peace
and happiness into one's life and when
someone has peace and happiness he's not
trying to blow nobody up especially
himself or innocent people
but you have these things going on but
this is a geopolitical thing and if you
were to add up all of these groups this
is just a side note i'm going out for
the tangent isis and all these groups
i'm sure you've heard and people out
there associate because some people are
going to watch this video they're going
to think you know again those those
because of the effect of the
islamophobia machine so take all these
radical groups compare that to the over
1.7 billion muslims all over the globe
it would only equate to if you have this
small fringe element to the 1.7 billion
last time i checked it would be like
0.006
it's like taking the kkk lowers the
resistance army or some of these these
secular atheists groups pkk
and all the taimo tigers all of these
these these these terrorist groups
and now you try to
pump them up
put them up as if they're exemplary
representatives of christianity
of secularism of atheism whatever is um
that wouldn't be fair there wouldn't be
rights you can't take a radical fringe
element and try to pump them up as if
they represent islam they don't they
don't represent habib they don't
represent me they don't represent the
over 1.7 billion muslims who again are
trying to keep it humble keep it simple
live a peaceful life
like everyone else people who have
connected with muslims john dutcher will
straight out tell you what he thought of
muslims i
actually
hated muslims the women with their
headdress on you know i just would sneer
at him dutcher was surrounded by the
people he loathed but muslims moving in
moved him it took this to yeah to to
wake me you know wake me up yeah a
change of heart for the man who didn't
realize he had such a big heart
you know
what struck me the most honestly was
when i took a minute to actually talk
to some of the muslim people to find out
you know they are just like me and i am
uneducated on their religion
you know i could easily make as many
mistake judgment calls as any other
person out there but when i took a
second to sit down and listen to them
and
actually enter their mosque and go on
and watch some of their prayers it was a
beautiful thing and they answered some
of my questions that i had
and i just feel that maybe that that's
something that they they should do too
for the people a lot a lot of us are
uneducated you know educate us on your
religion let us know that not
everybody's a bad bad person said i am
very glad
to see you here thank you for being here
this is america
and i just want to say as a christian to
all my muslim brothers and sisters
that we are glad to have you
we are you are our neighbors we stand
with you we will resist any attempts to
hurt you and
please reach out to us we will reach out
to you thank you very much have made the
human connection they've seen past all
the fear-mongering and all the hype and
now
that's it we're going to curtail it one
more i got a bonus for you what's he
doing in the back here what's he doing
in the back some people might see this
picture and there's a there's a black
house or cube this is
[Applause]
khabib like
many muslims make this journey once in a
lifetime if you're physically and
financially able it's the first house of
worship get this built by abraham to
commemorate the worship of the one god
remember islam is based on five pillars
one anyone can be a muslim
habib tod berger came here from the u.s
of jewish ancestry raised a christian he
converted islam two years ago
all pilgrims here wear the simple white
ichram and all markers of social status
disappear so my family has concerns and
issues
and they also
recognize that i have a deep connection
with
god with the one god i believe that
people have no idea what islam is
originally from texas habib now lives in
california
he says his biggest challenge is to
change misconceptions in america about
islam
it's
it's unfortunate that
the media in the states has portrayed
islam as it is
because there's no connection between
terrorism and islam
as arafat day draws to an end
many like habib continue their prayers
in the spot where muslims say prophet
muhammad delivered his last sermon the
other four pillars if you didn't know
are to testify what's in your very
nature it's natural to believe in the
creator they've done scientific studies
of the god spot and all of us
at oxford university not too long ago
they did a study and they concluded that
the belief
in a creator is intrinsic
it's innate it's built in all of us
disbelief is something acquired
so you do something that is natural
that's within your capability that you
give birth to what's already inside you
that there's nothing worthy of worship
nothing in the creation except the one
who created the creation the one god the
creator and muhammad is the last and
final messenger this will automatically
include not exclude
every messenger that came before him
with the same message submit your will
to god almighty allah that is the first
pillar second is to establish the prayer
five times a day minimum
not because god needs it because we need
it we need a recharge of the heart to
keep it humble otherwise we get
we get taken away by this temporal world
and we don't
remember we forget
that this life is a test and we got to
prepare
ourselves for the day of judgment and
we're going to be judged and evaluated
just like in high school college there's
an evaluation this life is that and
those five pillars help us
to remain cognizant of our purpose in
life and the third is giving in charity
to the poor zakat fasting during the
month of ramadan
and this is something jesus did all the
messengers of god did they were all
muslims ones who submit to the will of
god khabib is a muslim one who submits
to god you could be a muslim anyone
could be a muslim any time this is what
a muslim is
and it was our humble attempt to
familiarize you with some of the things
that this mma fighter does so next time
you see him you watch him you can
appreciate them it's not something
something that
is foreign to you now strange we've
connected it to things that you can
relate to
and if you want to know more call us
1-800-662-islam
and
reach out connect visit the muslims you
know there's a lot of misinformation out
there i quoted you from time magazine
all of these
these
books that have been published the the
industry of bashing islam but we need to
connect
as humans connect as humanity so we can
work to make the world a better place
and we're not going to do it through
fear and fear mongering we're not going
to do it through this hate hate breeds
hate we need this is that that the
educational process that will help solve
these problems the human connection is
another main factor
we're doing our small little part
and i hope that you can tune in with us
every week to the dean show where we
help clear many of these misconceptions
and to our brother
khabib
god willingness gets to him we can like
to have you been out this show that show
aerial hawaii show you can make it
inshallah with your brother
on the deen show i have my people reach
out to your people and inshallah god
willing we can make the connections
and we can get to meet and have you on
the program
thank you very much everybody tuning in
we'll see you next time same time same
channel here on the dean show
like this video subscribe if you haven't
already
peace be with you psalm nick